it's been ten years since Rockstar  released bully and now we've got a new  way to play it I'm Tony and this is a  GameSpot news update anniversary bully  anniversary edition is out now for both  iOS and Android the port comes to us  from war drum studios who previously  brought Grand Theft Auto and Max Payne  to mobile devices the game packs in  everything from bully scholarship  edition plus better graphics and  lighting and new touch-based controls  friend challenges also take the game's  goofy minigames and let you compete  against your buddies for high scores so  if you ever wanted to take bully on the  go now you can bully anniversary edition  will cost you 7 bucks on either platform  bully is also available on ps4 with full  trophy support if that's your thing  what other rockstar games do you want to  see on mobile devices let me know in the  comments or on twitter at chaingun hope  and for all the biggest game news you're  already in the right place